stupid stupid shirt look at that look at
this hair oh my god I mean so be honest
this is a pretty cool shirt except it's
a trump shirt my name is Ryan and I'm a
Trump supporter my name is Ali and I
support Hillary Clinton my foremost
agreement with Donald Trump his economic
policies I said with Hillary Clinton
because I'm in line with a lot of her
the things that she has spent her life
fighting for health care gun control
reproductive rights when I find out who
people's support
I sometimes judge them immediately if I
hear or see somebody supporting Hillary
Clinton I assume they support a liar or
someone who's hiding emails or in
scandals I definitely judge Trump
supporting people view Trump supporters
as racists as uneducated as liars and as
extremists or radicals I'm none of the
above it's hard for me to respect people
who support him because it makes me sick
the things that he says about people of
other races and genders
this is such like an old-school hat
which is probably like why people don't
think she's cool
Hillary claims it for President boys and
girls this is making me excited this is
why people hate America this is why
other nations don't take us seriously
people are gonna love this one I feel
like if someone sees me wearing this
they have to think it's a joke great I'm
so ready to get out here and get some
people's reactions we're gonna find out
the hard way what this is like
so I'm wearing my Hillary hat today
today I'm going to the dogs from golf
course of Palos Verdes before I went to
the Trump golf course I called the
course to make sure that it was okay if
I wore Hillary gear there and they
advised me not to they feel a little bit
like a fraud just a minute ago I was
ordering water and the man that gave me
the water said oh you're a young man
voting for Hillary and he was like very
surprised about it I kind of felt like I
was judged a little bit for that for
being young man as if I'm not supposed
to vote for Hillary a male co-worker
came up to me and was like oh I love
Hillary I'm voting for two and it was
cool to see a young person and a young
guy be really enthusiastic one guy just
came up to me and asked me why I support
Hillary I like being asked why no one
has said anything negative or mean about
it they accept actually when I first
walked in a few people I'm sitting
around her like really a couple of
Bernie supporters just yelled at me and
told me that Hillary is all for the
corporate world and that I shouldn't
support the corporate world it's a
little weird to wear any sort of a
political statement on my body
it has security I walked by somebody a
minute ago and they asked me if I lost a
bet because of what I'm wearing the
papal day has come today I'm walking on
my campus at USC and I'm already getting
all sorts of dirty looks for I was come
here somebody just passed by me said Wow
a pair of girls just pointed at me and
laughed so one of my friends told me
that he should follow me around and
protect me because of what I'm wearing
the most negative reaction I got for in
the Trump gear was the assistant at my
chiropractor's office I walked in and
she noticed I was wearing the truck gear
and she says to me you want people like
me deported and I was pretty shocked I
was like no I don't want you deported
you're the assistant at my
chiropractor's why would I want that
it's scarier than I thought it would
either I am standing in the dahle Trump
golf course a sort of little old lady
just told me I looked very cute just had
a lady come up and asked me to take a
picture with her now I'm gonna go get
ice cream with Ella
we were just going across the street to
get ice cream like literally across the
street and she wouldn't go with me in a
trump shirt she like made me take it off
I just went to a small Mexican joint one
of the guys was pointing at me and
looking at me kind of angrily he seemed
like he didn't like me
it made me realize that the political
climate right now
scares me there's so much tension I now
feel a lot warmer to other political
candidates supporters now I've heard so
much with the red earth comes from other
people which makes me understand them a
little more when they agree to this
video I had no idea the emotional toll
it would take on me to where Donald
Trump stuff when I was running the
Hillary gear getting some positive
responses from people made me realize
okay people feel warm sometimes with
Hillary I guess it's cool to see other
people's points of view today it's cool
to care about politics because then it
means that you you know care about what
you believe in and you're willing to
fight for what you believe all people
have their reasons for voting for a
certain candidate and I can realize that
now and it shouldn't be something that
we chastise each other on instead we
should be open to learning of other
people's opinions don't judge people for
what they feel just listen